[Music]
here you go anything else i can do thank
you
what happened to foreign michael it's
okay two minutes is too soon five
minutes and two minutes is a very big
difference
[Music]
[Laughter]
this hair plantation
is running low on greenbacks
um
we ain't got enough money to pay the
people who sell us the sides and the
menu i can't do this
michael basically
[Laughter]
that was almost impossible
uh
aaron have you seen
michael oh
oh hey there you are
hey take that gap just for the record i
think you're overreacting a little bit
your mom's old enough to make her own
decisions oh well thanks oscar i was
just wondering how would you feel if
michael was sleeping with your mom
my mother's in a wheelchair
that was so sincere just for the record
i'm reacting just a little bit
i'm sorry it's late my mother's in a
wheelchair
i can't do it if you're laughing
i had to make a snap decision dwight no
you didn't you were sitting there for an
hour it was a lot of snap decisions
you popped the trunk why did you
michael because i this isn't my car it's
for the show
the property you're looking at is in
great shape and the equipment's 100
pristine are you looking to preserve it
whoa whoa something major happened was
it my fault installed poorly okay
i know bob vance dwight schrute i work
next door just give him a call
call bob vance call bob vance
bob
just
forget it mr schrute are you looking to
preserve it as a munitions class just
i'll call you back
and we don't want them at our wedding
thinking jim's being marched down the
aisle by my dad with a shotgun
but there's not gonna be a shotgun no
no shotgun that changes everything
can't back out now help her what are you
gonna do about it there's no shotgun
you just did a classic gym face at the
end of that it was so cute
classic gym that was like gym season two
i dusted off an oldie
you should see their baby
so i guess you recognize everybody else
you all right yep she's drunk
[Laughter]
wow rain
the rain what sorry
wow
you coming ring
oh
whoa whoa
ellie i think we're out of fax cover
sheets
who
shut it
yep still breathing
jim i said not till she's older okay
just a few of the pranks we do here
we finally have a prank
okay wait there it is uh it is rumored
that they will
declare
i can't i can't see it
um
you don't know your lies
yes michael what is so urgent david
guess who i'm dressed up
sorry
one more time
you should have like i do i have the
lines right in front of me i know i've
painted them on the inside of my eyes
[Music]
shut up it's hard to say your name
i'm sorry muggle you don't have to do
this i'm gonna do this
where it's wrong with yourself
oh god
you said you would laugh
hey so
jim thought it would be right
so jim thought
yeah i'm happy because if jim and pam
can't
yeah i'm thrilled because if jim and pam
can't be employee of the month nobody
can that's real fair
oh that's the greatest thing i've ever
seen i just got out of the restroom and
it stinks the warehouse needs to go okay
wait how do you know it's the warehouse
who stunk up the bathroom
because they stink up the bathroom
no okay wait how do you know it's a
warehouse worker that's dunked up the
bathroom they stink up the bathroom with
their smelly poo so
they're going to turn on us come on
i can't talk
kevin will be eaten pam will be taken
slave
and he will be made a warlord's jester
and meredith will do just fine what can
i do
your skull will be man
what can i do
your skull will be made of soup ball
so yeah what can i do your skull will be
made of soup bowl cool
what's
going on
what can i do
you're
sorry i'm sorry what can i do
your skull will be a soup bowl
cool
it's hard to live this way i don't know
how you uh
how you do it man you gotta just
just not care what people think about
you at all
you'll learn baby
i don't know how you do it man i can't
be so cold
feel her baby you're wrong
not
good i don't know how you do it
i don't know how you do it you creamy
you can live it buddy
you're not even enjoying it
it's not about the enjoyment it's about
well this is all for michael um sorry
okay
okay this is our first time i know i
know we're here two girls
yeah oh yeah okay all right all right
rather than spend the whole day in court
we decided to settle our dispute using a
mediator it was one of the options
spelled out in our child-rearing
contract alleged contract what are you
talking about the contract is alleged
you wrote the contract dwight you were
notarized
sorry
i used to be a cheetah
till i saw a love actually
yeah what's your point here's my point
here's the church here's the steeple
open it up
there's all the people cheating on other
people okay do this do this
[Laughter]
you knew
good day hello dwight schrute archie
barr
i'm sorry archie barr
that's his name dwight
eat spicy foods what is the opposite of
that make spicy foods come out of her
okay nope no
eat spicy foods okay okay what is the
opposite of that spicy foods come out of
it nope okay nope nope we're not doing
that pam
okay so what is it eat spicy foods and
the opposite of that oh make spicy food
[Laughter]
hey
worker
do you use the ladder or the lift
drift we use the drift
are you crying toby
are you crying
you